so let's get started with this framework
first step in the framework is a series
of caveats
so caveat that's a fancy word for watch
out so what do you want to watch out for
so I have a friend very successful
healthcare venture capitalist and he
said there's the difference between
literature meaning a business plan or an
idea for new venture and life meaning
the reality of that new venture
he said literature is all romance and no
children he didn't use the word romance
you know what word he used
but life life it's all children and no
romance and he said that's the way it is
with healthcare innovation the
literature and the business plan it's
full of hearts and flowers but the
reality is very hard so how do you know
what's literature and how do you know
what's life well one thing you should be
very careful of or true believers so
true believers are the missionaries who
have created this new venture and they
deeply believe in it they're passionate
about it it's so passionate that they
may not see the world the way you would
see the world so don't believe that true
believers I don't mean they're liars
some people are most or not what I mean
is they see the world differently from
the way that you may see the world so
how do you get a reality check on the
world you need to go back to basics so
if somebody says
the market for telemedicine is thirty
billion dollars would he even do with us
well he have to understand the basics
how many people are going to be using
telemedicine what will they be using it
for who is actually going to pay for
this how much are they willing to pay
and you've got to do this area by area
of application cuz the answers all
differ so right away you know that
innovating in healthcare it's not all
high level stories gotta get a lot of
dirt under the fingernails in order to
do it appropriately